In this shot from 1950's
"Destination Moon,"
these stars were actually
2,000 light bulbs
from car headlights.
It was probably the most
realistic portrayal of space
at the time,
but 68 years and several
real-life space missions later,
"First Man" used
state-of-the-art LED screens
to project realistic renders
of the solar system
and the moon's surface,
even adding a reflection
on Ryan Gosling's helmet.
It took decades of technical breakthroughs
to get to this point,
from intricate wirework
and robotic cameras
to CG legs floating in zero gravity.
Here's how space scenes have
transformed over 120 years.
Long before humankind took
their first steps on the moon,
filmmakers sought to bring
their stories to space.
In 1902's "A Trip to the Moon,"
director Georges Méliès
created the illusion
of a capsule landing in the moon
using a substitution splice,
first shooting the actor playing the moon,
then adding the capsule in another shot
and combining the two frames.
While this iconic shot
is obviously fantastical,
"Destination Moon" wanted to be
as scientifically accurate as possible.
However, the filmmakers
had both a limited scientific
understanding of space
and a limited toolbox for special effects.
In addition to using light bulbs
for the stars in deep space,
the cast also used a matte
painting as a backdrop
with small cracks to create the illusion
of perspective on the moon.
But the biggest innovation at the time?
Wires.
To create the illusion of low gravity,
director Irving Pichel attached the actors
to piano wire run through a pulley system
and controlled by an overhead crane.
This effectively lifted
the actors off the ground,
but keeping the wires
from showing up on camera
was a lot of work.
According to writer Robert
Heinlein, the set lights
could make the wires visible
on camera during filming.
If the wires were seen in the take,
they'd have to start all over again.
The movie also wanted to
show characters moving
as the ship left Earth's orbit.
To create the illusion of a person
walking around all sides of the ship,
the crew built the set
with a fixed camera and two gimbals.
That way, the camera could
rotate in sync with the set.
It was similar to the rig
that allowed Fred Astaire
to famously dance on walls
in 1951's "Royal Wedding."
All of these innovations
took a lot of time and money.
As Heinlein wrote, "Realism
is confoundedly expensive."
Perhaps for that reason,
space scenes throughout
the 1950s and 1960s
frequently relied on the audience's
suspension of disbelief.
Take this shot of a flying saucer
in "Plan 9 from Outer Space."
It's clearly just a toy on a string,
but that would all change
drastically in 1968
with "2001: A Space Odyssey."
Now that humans had
actually gone to space,
Stanley Kubrick needed to redefine
what futuristic life in
space would look like.
And he did so by pushing the
limits of visual effects.
When it came to wires, Kubrick found
that by simply placing
the camera on the ground,
the actors' bodies
would naturally block the wires from view.
But the zero-g illusions
got much more elaborate.
The team built a 38-foot-tall centrifuge
that rotated at 3 miles per hour
to imitate artificial gravity.
Unlike the rotating set
in "Destination Moon,"
this one had two cameras:
a mounted one that
moved along with the set
and a dolly camera that
moved with the actors.
But not all the sets were gigantic.
These models were much
more detailed, elaborate,
and closer to real NASA
spacecraft at the time,
thanks to Kubrick's famously
obsessive attention to detail.
To make the miniatures
look like they were moving,
the camera was driven along the track
on a motorized mount around the models.
This method made it possible
to exactly repeat camera moves.
The crew would do one
pass of the Discovery,
another pass of the stars,
and then combine it all
into one seamless shot.
Kubrick basically created
an early form of motion-control cameras.
And these new cameras
revolutionized the space saga
with "Star Wars."
With "A New Hope," George
Lucas wanted to create
awe-inspiring space chases and battles,
and audiences could be right in the action
thanks in part to a man named John Dykstra
and his new camera,
called the Dykstraflex.
The Dykstraflex was
programmed by a computer
to move around the
miniatures in such a way
to create the illusion of
speeding through space,
like this imposing angle of the underbelly
of a Star Destroyer
or this shot during
the Death Star dogfight
that appears to be from
a pilot's point of view.
The camera's precise programming
also made shots easily repeatable
for seamless compositing.
It's why multiple models
could be shot separately
and then combined during the dogfight.
It's also why the Death Star
really looks like it's
floating up in space,
when in reality this close-up
was shot in a parking lot.
Motion-control cameras can be seen
again and again in space movies.
They were used in the "Star Wars" sequels
throughout the 1980s and
all the way through 2014
for the practical models
of "Interstellar."
But all of these movies were
about fictional space travel.
Things needed to be a lot more
realistic with "Apollo 13."
Houston, we have a problem.
Oh, boy, what's going on here?
Flight, let me get back to you.
Narrator: So director
Ron Howard put the cast
in actual zero-g for wider shots.
It was the first movie
ever shot on NASA's KC-135,
where real astronauts
trained for space conditions
at the time.
The plane flies up 35,000 feet in the air
before plunging back to Earth.
This renders all passengers
weightless for 25 seconds --
no wires needed.
The crew only had 25
seconds per ride to shoot,
so the filmmakers broke down
each scene into small chunks
and then later used wires
on set for close-ups.
In total, the cast and
crew took 612 flights,
adding up to nearly four
hours of weightlessness.
Shooting on the Vomit
Comet looks authentic,
but the limited zero-g windows
make it a logistical nightmare.
And what do you do for shots
that need to be much longer?
"Gravity" contained harrowing
continuous takes in space
that lasted as long as 15 minutes,
making it difficult to both move
and light the actors properly.
We went to incredible lengths
on the movie "Gravity"
to portray microgravity or zero gravity.
Narrator: First, the crew relied
on previsualized animations
that showed what the movie would look like
before shooting took place.
Studying hours of reference footage
to create the digital characters
also helped them imitate
weightlessness more accurately.
Chris: People do not move slowly
as though they're underwater in space.
That's a common misconception.
If you watch those astronauts,
they move really quickly,
'cause there's no air resistance.
Narrator: To tackle the sequence
where a debris storm hits the characters,
director Alfonso Cuarón
and cinematographer Emmanuel Lubezki
invented a new technology
called a light box.
Chris: We were going to run for 15 minutes
without a hard cut.
We had to be able to plan the lighting
and have perfect continuity,
because everything was going
to need to sit together.
Narrator: The light box
built on existing technology.
Sandra Bullock and George Clooney
were strapped into tilt rigs
while their space journey
was captured by motion-control cameras.
All of that was inside a
box covered with LED panels
that could, for example,
show real images of Earth
from space as the backdrop.
Because it was all programmed,
they could change up the lighting
faster than any normal studio light,
which came in handy for the scene
where they're hit by space debris.
Movies like "First Man"
built on the light box
and went even further with LED screens.
Director Damien Chazelle
used a 35-foot-tall,
65-foot-wide LED screen
to provide dynamic 180-degree
views of space in real time.
That meant the Gemini
space capsule leaving Earth
could be captured in-camera.
And because this life-size
model was motorized,
the camera didn't need
to fake any movements.
You could even get this
convincing lunar reflection
on Ryan Gosling's helmet.
Making the moon realistic
took a lot of effort as well.
Neil Armstrong's moonwalk
was shot in a quarry at night
that was manicured with gravel
to replicate the moon's surface.
Later, that footage was combined
with real surface scans of
the moon provided by NASA.
It's the tiny details like this
that really sold "First Man."
Look at this shot.
The extra dust that clouds each footstep
was added entirely with CG.
And CGI might be the answer
when it comes to truly
mimicking zero-g movement.
Gravity's impossible to get away from.
You just, you're constantly under it.
Narrator: Framestore made great strides
in digital doubles in "The Midnight Sky,"
making weightlessness look
more real than ever before.
You hold your limb out and swing around,
you kind of feel gravity doing its thing.
We were able to completely eliminate that.
Narrator: Digital doubles
allowed filmmakers
to conquer more challenging
weightless scenes,
like these wide shots of
crew outside the Aether.
This actor was minimally wired up on set,
but his legs were swapped
out with a digital pair
so there was no hint
of real-world gravity.
Fewer wires meant they
didn't have to worry about
where the camera was placed,
as they did in "Space Odyssey."
The team also used a virtual camera system
where the cinematographer
referenced an iPad
showing rough animated footage.
By pointing it around an empty room,
he could physically block out the shots.
This level of planning
allowed the spacewalk
to feature 70 fully CG performances.
Chris: The technology has
come so far in the 10 years
since we did "Gravity"
that you can do these things
in quite a lightweight way,
and it is interactive and
easy enough for a director
to just hold an iPad
and look around the set.
Narrator: The result is a series of shots
where digital movements, wire stunts,
and even hidden crew members
lifting objects into the air
all contribute to make space travel
both terrifying and awe-inspiring.
Chris: So we've come a
long way since "Apollo 13,"
and, indeed, we've come a
long way since "Gravity."
Narrator: Méliès made a capsule fly
so Kubrick could defy the laws of gravity
so Cuarón could capture the
light of the solar system.
Each might seem like a
small step on its own,
but taken all together, it
was one giant leap for cinema,
one dust cloud at a time.